il a beau être à l'aube de ses quarante
sept ans et avoir raccroché les crampons
en 2006 marco simonet a toujours faim de
ballons et communique cette envie à son
groupe le coach a surtout été un
attaquant prolifique en but près de 200
inscrits en 18 saisons professionnelles
le football lui a offert de grandes
émotions
il veut aujourd'hui on fait revivre de
semblable à ses joueurs
mon objectif est de pouvoir donner
commander delà de la joie cette équipe
voir la joie dans l'équipe pour cela
marque aussi monnaie a décidé de jouer
toutes les compétitions à 100% le
championnat de ligue 2 bien sûr où le
tfc est actuellement 12ème et les coupes
quel que soit l'adversaire
le déplacement à lorient n'effraie pas
les tourangeaux ils ont prouvé en coupe
de la ligue jusqu'à une courte défaite à
lyon en 8e de finale qu'il pouvait tenir
la dragée haute aux équipes de ligue 1
le match de lyon aussi a été quelque
chose de positif pour nous parce qu on a
montré qu'on pouvait jouer face à des
équipes de haut niveau de haut niveau
donc voilà à lorient c'est aussi une
équipe de ligue 1 donc faudrait être
créés et surtout que ce sera un contexte
différent un petit peu de ce qu'on a pu
connaître à lyon mais ce sera aussi la
reprise pour eux donc je pense qu'aussi
long du manche et quelques chocolats
le tours football club qui n'a jamais
fait mieux qu'une demi-finale peut donc
espérer franchir un premier palier ce
dimanche
histoire de faire honneur à marco simone
et vainqueur lui de la coupe de france
en 1998 sous le maillot du psg